لا أعتقد أن لدينا ما يكفي من
القوى العاملة من الأطباء الموجودين في
الخطوط الأمامية لتحديد
مشاكل الكحول وعلاجها ، فنحن نريد تغيير
النظام حقًا من الداخل إلى الخارج ، مما يمنح
المرضى خيارات أفضل
مثل الأدوية التي يستخدمها الفريق في
مختبر الإدمان  الاختبار
ووفقًا لبيلي ، فإن الحبوب التي
يتناولها تعمل ،
لذا عندما أعطيت الحبوب لأول مرة
أي آثار جانبية أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
وفي الأيام القليلة الأولى كنت مستاءً
في المعدة ولكن في اليوم الثالث
كنت أتناولها.  الكحول
الذي هو مدهش للغاية أعتقد
أنك لم تشعر أنك بحاجة إلى الكحول
، لقد كان الأمر غريبًا ، لقد نجح
بسرعة كبيرة ، الدواء المستخدم في
تجربة بيلي المسمى ibutalast هو مُعدِّل مناعي
عصبي أثبت
فعاليته في الحد من الإفراط في تناول الكحول
وتقليل الدماغ.  استجابة المكافأة لإشارات الكحول كانت
المدة التي مرت منذ أن
شربت اليوم خمسة خمسة أشهر في
أسبوع واحد خمسة أشهر في أسبوع واحد
وهذا كل شيء في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع  هذا كثير
بالنسبة لي ، لذا فأنت في الشهر الخامس من تجربة ستة
أشهر ،
ماذا يحدث عندما ينتهي الأمر
جيدًا ، أريد أن يستمر الدواء
عندما ينتهي ، أريد أن أحصل عليه بنفسي
لأنني لا أريد الخروج
منه  المشكلة هي أن الدواء الذي يتناوله بيلي
ليس متاحًا بعد ، حتى الآن
،
حصلت على موافقة إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية (FDA) ،
ولكني لم أحصل على موافقة إدارة الغذاء والدواء (FDA) على
الدواء في
بعض الأحيان ، فماذا يحدث إذا نجح
مع الأشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون ذلك؟
احصل عليه بعد ذلك إذا لم يكن متاحًا محبطًا للغاية ،
فنحن نريد أن تكون هذه العملية
أسرع إذا أردنا حقًا أن يكون لديهم
شيء جديد سيكون أفضل
من المعايير الحالية